- She's an inspiration to Alicia, myself,
and millions of women worldwide.
She's an author, an activist,
her latest book "Untamed"
was released in March and has already sold
over 1 million copies.
I am two of those.
Please welcome Glennon Doyle, everybody!
(audience applauding)
Okay, so first of all.
- Hi Kelly!
- I love that you two actually
already know each other, right?
- We're connected.
- We do.
Well I have, yes, deeply connected.
I have actually been deeply connected
to Alicia for decades,
but she just found out
about it a couple years ago.
(Kelly laughs)
We just started the two-way
friendship recently.
It's just been me singing her songs
and crying in the shower for
many, many years until now.
- That's all of us.
But Glennon, so many
people have read "Untamed",
especially people that I know.
And they've found inspiration.
But for people not
familiar, what is it about?
What would you say if you
had to give a synopsis?
- Well the storyline,
the main storyline going
through it, is I was in a
broken marriage to a good man,
and that is a hard place for a woman
to be because we're
supposed to be grateful
for what we have and
good enough is supposed
to be good enough.
But as that marriage,
as we were struggling
to kind find some
unbrokenness, I fell madly
in love with a woman.
And I don't know, when I met her this part
of me rose up that I had
abandoned a long time ago,
and I just was faced with this kind
of life-or-death situation it felt like.
Like, am I going to abandon the self
because I'm too afraid to
rock the boat of my life?
- Mm-hm.
- Or am I going to abandon
everyone else's expectations
of me and honor myself for
the first time in my life?
- Alicia's freakin' out right now!
I don't know if you
can see her (laughing).
And you did, you did.
- [Glennon] I did honor myself.
- You did "Me X 7", that's one
of her new songs. (laughing)
(Alicia squealing and laughing)
- [Glennon] Yes I did.
When we do finally honor ourselves,
we have been trained to believe that
that will somehow hurt our people,
and sometimes it makes them
uncomfortable at first.
But what happens when we honor ourselves
is we give permission to
everyone else in our families
and our lives to honor themselves also.
So it's a freedom that is contagious.
- Yeah, what a great domino effect, yes.
So Glennon we have an important election
in less than three weeks, and Alicia
and I were talking a little bit
about, you know just what's happening
in the world right now.
I will say, I have totally
stalked you online,
I've seen everything and I
know all your story. (laughing)
But one thing I love that you talk about,
and I think it was actually a couple years
ago maybe even that you
first started talking
about, but people were like, "Oh my gosh,
2020's gonna be the death,
everything is horrible,
it's the apocalypse."
And I loved that it takes
sometimes that deconstruction,
that blowing up of
things, to actually sort
out all the crap that's actually wrong.
Are you hopeful or are you still kind
of like, "Oh my gosh,
like what's happening?"
- Two things, I mean I
use the word apocalypse.
Apocalypse means uncovering.
- Yep.
- Right?
So in terms of what this time is doing,
none of this that's happening, none
of this injustice and
inequality is new at all, right?
Which is why my activist
friends aren't the ones saying,
"Oh my God, 2020 is the worst!"
They're actually feeling
hopeful because this is,
all of this inequality has been going on
for a very long time.
It's just that now people
are finally seeing it because
of the apocalypse, uncovering of COVID.
As to whether I'm hopeful or not,
I heard Stacey Abrams say the other day.
Someone said, "Are you hopeful?"
And she said, "I am neither
hopeful nor pessimistic,
I am determined."
- Ooh!
- And I loved that so much because
as someone who's sober, I
rely on what I can control.
And I know what I can't
control is outcome,
so pessimism and optimism
are reliant on outcome.
But determinism, being
determined, that all has
to do with our input, how
we're showing up, right?
So what I know is I am
determined over the next weeks
to get every single untamed woman I know
to refuse being gaslit,
to know what she knows,
feel what she feels, and
to show up at the polls
on November 3rd.
(audience applauding)
- Amen!
Alicia, how are you
feeling about everything?
Like the voting and everything?
I know that everybody
always gets frustrated
with people in the music
world and art world
and they're like, "Just be artistic!"
And I'm like yes, but also
like I'm not pushing my views
on you but you have to realize how I think
because we've traveled,
we see how lucky we are,
how fortunate we are to be able to vote.
I don't know, I feel like it's kind
of your duty as an American citizen
to say something like that, you know?
- I mean it is, it is all
of our responsibility.
It's all of our opportunity
and definitely it is,
it's something that we should
all feel really actually
excited and passionate about, you know?
We can all learn so much more.
I think that's one thing
that I think about a lot.
You don't have to know it all.
I think that's one of the
things that feels intimidating,
you're like, "Whoa, I'm not
sure" and how about this?
And it's okay that you don't know it all.
And it's okay to actually
start to learn more.
I think that's something
that I'm asking my friends
and family and also just
anybody who's connecting
with me, like let's take a moment
to actually dig into
the parts we don't know.
Let's dig into the parts of the ballot
that maybe we are a
little bit insecure about
or the names that we're
not so clear about,
or the policies that maybe
don't make perfect sense,
or that we didn't take the
time to look into enough yet.
It's okay, it's all a growing process
and it's all a part of
actively being a human being.
You know, and actively being able
to be a participant in what
this whole thing looks like.
I mean, this is up to us.
This is not something where
it's like, "Oh we're gonna hope
that that one guy or
woman does the thing."
No!
One person can't do
anything all by themselves.
We all need to show up.
We have to show up for our
families, for our own kids,
for our sisters and brothers,
for our communities.
Because if we're not showing
up, no one else is gonna be
like, "Oh hey, what's
happening in your spot?
'Cause I care so much about you."
No, we have to care about ourselves.
- Yeah.
- We have to care about
ourselves enough to show up.
So it's less about that they're
gonna do all this stuff,
and we gotta show up for us, you know?
Less about them, more about us.
And let's learn about what
we can so that we can align
with people that have
similar beliefs and thoughts.
(audience applauding)
But man, this is for us, we gotta do this.
- Thank you so much, Glennon.
And thank you Alicia, thank you
for being open and honest.
(audience clapping)
That kind of rawness is so rare
in this world in the public eye.
So I really appreciate
it and I'm lifting both
of you up and everybody pick
up "Untamed" by Glennon Doyle.
I absolutely love this book
and it's available everywhere.
Also pick up "Alicia"!
Her new album "Alicia" is out right now!